Pour ne louper aucune vidéo,
abonnez-vouset activez la petite cloche !
Salut les Épicurieux.
Vous connaissez ce dessert ?
C'est " la célèbretarte Tatin ".
Ou plus précisément,
la tarte des soeurs Tatin.
Stéphanie et Caroline
tenaientl'hôtel Tatin à Lamotte-Beuvron en Sologne,
entre 1894 et 1906.
Ça ne date pas d'hier !
Elles auraientinventé cette tarte aux pommes
par mégarde en la renversant ou en oubliant la pâte.
La réalitéest probablement un peu moins romanesque
bien qu'on ne sache pas exactement ce qui s'est passé.
Ce n'est pas de la tarte !
Un carnet datant de cette époque
et appartenant à l'institutrice de lacommune
décrit cette recette.
Avec une mention à la fin,
" cette recette a été inventé par lacuisinière
du comte de Chateauvillard
qui l'a ensuite transmise à Stéphanie Tatin ".
Par conséquent, les soeurs Tatin n'auraient pas inventé la tarte Tatin
mais elles l'ont considérablement améliorée
et rendue extrêmement célèbre.
A tel point qu'aujourd'hui ce dessert est inscrit
aupatrimoine immatériel de l'UNESCO.
Tiens en fait,
vous savez comment on fait une tarte
Tatin dans le sud ?
Tu fais une tarte,
tu la mets au four
et " Tatin " !
Bon je sais c'est uneblague pourrie,
on ne va pas en faire un plat.
A bientôt !